let's get to it true or false nipple
Gazans are a real thing welcome to three
strikes where today is gonna get a
little hot it's gonna get a little
steamy it's gonna get a little weird
that's right we're talking about sex
we've got two dating app users here to
my left
hi I'm Jenny I'm 25 and I'm a
Sagittarius and to my right my name is
Matt I'm 24 and I'm a Gemini okay so
here's the rules the first person to
miss three of these rapid-fire questions
is gonna have to delete their favorite
dating app and as a bonus consequence
because we're so nice here you're gonna
have to perform an embarrassing task
right here on the spot okay Jenny we're
gonna start with you and we're gonna go
to Matt and back and forth I remember
three strikes you gone let's get to it
true or false nipple gazans are a real
thing true true
that is correct Matt we're going to you
what is the big round booty muscle
called gluteus maximus oh my god Jenny
back to you what does PMS stand for you
oh my god mental syndrome call it on
that when it's premenstrual syndrome you
were so so close that's strike one for
you Jenny Matt we're going to you so
hard one spell the word syphilis s why
th i oh i whoa we got a spelling Pro
here Jenny we're going to you which
sensitive gland produces male seminal
fluid if it's here dairy no we were
looking for the prostate I'm sorry Matt
we're coming to you how long does the
average period lasts a week no we're
looking for three to five days just shy
of that that's the one strike format two
for you Jenny
true or false blue ball is a real thing
Oh true Jenny that's three strikes
why you guys I know I know dad that's
that's a tricky one
I'm sorry to say we're gonna have to
have you pop that phone out what's your
preferred dating app it's always a good
hinge is deleted you have your ex's
phone number in there a lot of scrolling
happens you're so refreshing to know
that we're kind of really going deep ok
I see you're typing this is really
happening
I am a bad person
I'm sorry for facilitating this type of
environment I know I am NOT gonna be
able to sleep tonight so me either
I'm glad that's not me there's what
happens when we ask the questions and
you don't have the answers there's
consequences all right tune in next time
to see who knows their stuff
and who's gonna strike out
you
[Music]